Salut à tous c’est Pêcheurs
de trésors, enfin...
Pêcheur de trésors...
Quentin et Rasta ne sont pas là
Ils sont en train
de dormir parce qu'ils travaillaient
tous les deux
cette nuit.
Rasta je ne très sûr
qu'il travaillait,
mais il dort quand
même.
Aujourd'hui,
je suis en compagnie
de Wim
et de Danny
et on est de retour
sur un spot que
vous avez déjà vu
On a déjà trouvé deux
pistolets ici.
On a trouvé des
tas de pièces,
des collections
entières
avec des pièces
de tous les pays.
De l'argent
(Silver coins)
Plein de choses !
Et aujourd’hui on est là pour trouver
D’autres pièces de monnaie en argent ou des pistolets
Oui des pistolets ce serait bien !
Vous avez toute
la chaîne
et ses réseaux
qui sont en
description
de la vidéo.
Je pense qu'on
peut faire
notre premier lancer,
Voyons voir ce que
ce pont nous réserve.
Je vais passer de l'autre
côté de la barrière,
Pour essayer de tirer plus fort
Sans tomber
C'est bon, ça c'est décollé, il y a du lourd
C'était un miroir mais il n'y a plus
la glace.
Danny, qui a trouvé
un panneau
et du gaz hilarant
et du protoxyde
d'azote
Malheureusement le panneau est retombé.
La dernière fois, quand Wim a pêché un
un panneau comme ça,
il y avait des bijoux
accrochés.
Joli lancé !
Oui j’étais debout sur ma corde
j'ai quelque chose,
une montre
Casio.
Ah non , Casino
What the fuck
Est-ce que je peux essayer ?
Ah tu veux essayer ?
Oh tu as une grosse barrière
J'ai besoin d'aide.
Thank you !
Un stylo.
Je pense qu'il ne fonctionne plus
Chargeur de pistolet à blanc ?
Je pense
Je pense que ça vient d’un faux c’est en plastique
C’est un airsoft
Oui c’est un airsoft parce que ici il y a le ressort pour les billes
Mais c’est bien c’est bien
Je crois que c'est un chargeur d'airsoft
OK. C'est quoi à droite ?
Une pochette
Une pochette de quoi ?
De lunettes
Elles ne sont
pas dedans.
Dolce Gabbana. Dommage
On va voir ce que j'ai
Du gaz hilarant
OK, encore
du protoxyde d'azote.
ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
Quelqu’un sait ce que c’est en commentaires ? Je ne connais pas moi
Incroyable
Un Sextoys.
Oh regarde il a 7 vitesses différentes
On va garder celui-ci pour Quentin
On va le mettre dans le riz, oh la pile est tombée
Belle découverte
Les filles laissez un commentaire
Je peux l’envoyer, Ah non c’est pour Quentin !
Désolé désolé
Découverte sympa
Félicitations
Première arme du jour
Un poids intéressant
Il sera plus propre
Peut être qu'il va trouver d'autres sextoys.
Il faut trouver un cockring
Un cockring en or
On en a besoin
J'ai quelque chose.
Je pensais que c’était une caisse de monnaie
Des francs
1 Franc
Je l’ajoute à ma collection de pièces
Bien joué pour la
collection de Francs
L'autre jour,
il a trouvé toute une
collection de pièces
de tous les pays.
Donc il en reste.
Son sac
était à moitié ouvert
Danny a trouvé un couteau
Il est beau
J’ai un Skateboard
Tu veux en faire ?
Oui juste ici
OK super.
Il est en état de fonctionnement
Plutôt puissants ces aimants
Wim et Danny utilisent aussi les aimants Magnetar
qui sont disponibles sur le site de Maison de la Détection
Code promo PECHEURDETRESORS
offre -5% sur toute la boutique
Vous avez toutes les informations en description
Un disque de frein
et une clé USB
Avec des bitcoins à l’intérieur
Qui sait ?
Je pense qu’un professionel saurait la lire
Peut-être deux millions de bitcoins
Tu trouves tout !
Trottinette
Elle fonctionne encore
aussi je pense.
On peut faire du skate et de la trotinette
Et je vais me servir de ça aussi
C'est parfait.
Super
Il y a de tout ici !
On continue
Qu'est
ce qu'on a de beau ?
Rasta me manque
un peu
Et Quentin, oups
Une barre de fer
Légère
Wim a un vélo
pas mal.
Il n'y a pas de roue
en plus.
C'est pratique
pour le ferrailleur
Allez, j'ai
quelque chose.
Peut être que c'est
de nouveau le pneu,
Ah non, ce n'est pas le pneu
Peut être qu'il va être
joli celui là ?
Il est gros, je vais sûrement le garder
On va regarder quel type de panneau c'est.
Il y a aussi un sac.
On va regarder dedans
Interdiction de stationner.
Tu peux en faire une table
On a aussi un stylo
Infiniti
Et le sac est vide
J'ai eu quelque chose
tout au fond.
Un poids correct.
J'espère que ce n'est pas encore un panneau
J'aime bien les panneaux,
mais il y en a assez.
En tout cas, ça ne lâche
pas, c'est bien accroché.
Il y a deux vélos
Un style de trottinette
qu'on n'avait jamais vu encore
Une trottinette pour enfant, c'est rigolo,
il a quatre roues.
Ca part sur Facebook.
Facebook
Market place.
Je vais récupérer
mon vélo.
C'est vrai
que ce n'est pas cool
de laisser ses vélos
dans le canal,
donc on va le sortir
Ah, il n'y est plus
Ah si
Il est là
On va l'attraper une troisième fois.
Et cette fois ci,
c'est la bonne.
Aller
Viens là mon petit.
Ce n'était pas la bonne.
Il commence à me me souler ce vélo
Ca fait quatre fois qu'il retombe
et je l'ai !
Les vélos sans roues je prend.
C'est plus simple
pour le ferrailleur
Si il veut bien
lâcher mon tee-shirt
Munitions.
Elle est pleine, calibre 12
Ce serait bien de trouver le fusil à pompe
1 franc de 1968
On a quelque chose qui était tout au fond
peut être
le fusil à pompe.
Ce serait énorme.
Ca a l'air plus lourd que ça.
Peut être
encore un vélo.
Ce n'est pas
étonnant ici.
Encore une trottinette, super !
Encore une différente
en plus.
Si jamais vous voulez acheter une trotinette
Contactez Baptiste
Oui on a tous types de modèles
Un de plus pour ton magasin
Merci merci j’avais loupé celui-ci
OK, un nœud papillon.
Chippendale
Un joli vélo bleu
Decathlon encore une fois
Incroyable de trouver autant de vélos.
Peut être qu'à force d'enlever
tous ces vélos,
on va trouver
les armes qui se cachent en dessous
Une boîte à lettres
une clé de voiture
Une clef de Nissan
Donc j'ai eu une partie d'ordinateur
Un autre pour le magasin
Une partie de l'ordi
HP
L'eau s'est mise à couler d'un coup
Ça vient d'où ?
J’ai été obligé de fuir regardez
Il a perdu son spot.
Et ça fait rire Baptiste
Oh c’est rempli de stylos
C'est une trousse.
C'est un collégien
qui en avait
marre de l'école.
Il voulait arrêter l’école
Oui il y a une école juste à côté
Qu’est-ce que c’est que ça ?
Beaucoup de stylos
C’est drôle
Belle découverte, Bravo !
Il est où votre chien ?
Qui c'est qui a jeté sa trousse avant d'aller au collège ?
- C'est moi !
Il est où le chien ?
Il arrive
cet après-midi
On a quelque chose, des essuies glace.
J'espère de marque Bosch
Depuis le début,
je suis encore
sur cette plateforme.
Sous le pont,
j'ai pas bougé
et ça n'arrête pas.
Je suis coincé et j’ai besoin d’un hollandais
Bien sûr,on va y arriver
Super merci !
OK, j'ai un truc
qui vient du bout.
Je dirais le poids
d'un vélo,
mais on va regarder
ensemble
ce qu'il y a au bout
de l'aimant.
OK, c'est un panneau.
Un capot de voiture
Il y a plein de moules
Alors
là j'ai un cadenas
et une boucle
d'oreille aussi
pas mal.
Elle est aimantée donc ce n'est pas de
l'or, c'est du toc.
C'est toujours sympa.
Enfin j'ai retrouvé l'ordinateur
Il faut y aller doucement parce qu'il est déjà
tombé une fois
On a une grosse pile
aussi avec ça.
Bonne dépollution.
J'ai peut être retrouvé la roue qui était tombée tout à l'heure.
Avec ça il y a un sac
On va essayer de la sortir cette fois
Regardez comme
il a plié la jante
Le sac malheureusement, j'ai l'impression qu'il est vide.
Juste
un sachet plastique,
Un aimant vide ?
Ah non
Un téléphone SFR
Super
OK, j'ai
quelque chose de lourd
Les gosses font un peu de bruit
Mais ils ne sont pas méchants.
Qu'est
ce que c'est que ça ?
C'est énorme !
C'est quoi ce chariot ?
Le couteau.
C'est un plan de travail pour les cuisines
Bien vu !
ça vient des cuisines
C'est pliable
Ca doit couter un paquet de sous ça
Il faut juste changer les roulettes.
Maintenant le récapitulatif
des meilleures trouvailles
Ce beau couteau
qui a été fait
par Wim, Bravo.
et le deuxième
couteau.
Pour Quentin,
il est pas mal
Avec le petit embout.
Encore une fois
c'est la troisième
à cet endroit.
Donc il y a peut être
quelqu'un
qui a des choses
à cacher
Il y a du scotch dessus.
Une clef USB en plus
Ecoutez, c'est
la fin de cette petit vidéo
On a trouvé déjà
plein de choses.
Merci encore à Wim
et à Danny
d'être venus.
Vous avez
leurs réseaux sociaux
en description
de la vidéo
Vous allez voir d'autres
vidéos avec eux
puisque Quentin
va nous rejoindre
et on va continuer
à pêcher à l'aimant cet après midi
pour la partie
deux. A bientôt.